What we would like to
build is a procedure for
reducing a system of equations
to a simple a form as possible.
Ideally, finding the unique
solution of a system if it exists.
We'll start by informally
describing the procedure and
using it to solve some
example systems of equations.
Then we'll explore some special cases
that can occur during the algorithm.
Once we have a better intuition about
the algorithm then we'll begin to write
code which will define
the algorithm's precise operation.
The algorithm we will discuss is
a classic algorithm called Gaussian
elimination.
Though it is named after the nineteenth
century German mathematician,
Carl Gauss.
The algorithm was known to the Chinese
as early as the second century BCE.
The basic idea of Gaussian elimination
is to gradually clear variables and
successive equations.
So the first equation will have
all the variables x, y, and z.
Then the next equation will
end up with just y and z.
And then the last equation
will just have z.
That way the last equation just
becomes z equals some number and
then since the second
equation only has y and
z and we know the value of z,
this allows us to find the value of y.
Finally, we use the values of y and
z in the first equation to find
the value of x, giving us the solution.
Presuming there is a unique solution,
after all.
We can do this by adding or
subtracting appropriate amounts of an
equation from all equations underneath.
Let's look at this example system.
x-3y+z = 4.
-3x+9y+z = 0 and y-z = 1.
In order to clear the x term
from the second equation,
we can add to three times the first
equation and to the second.
Remember that adding or
subtracting multiples of
equations is a valid operation.
This transforms the second
equation into 4z = 12.
Now we could go ahead and use the second
equation to find the value of z.
But for now we're going to ignore
the short cut and show how the procedure
works in general like we did before
with the x term in the first equation.
We want there to be a y term
in the second equation,
so that we can use it to clear y
terms below the second equation.
That way we have successive
loss of variables.
If like in this case, there is no
y term in the second equation,
we look to below the second equation for
one with a y term.
Then we can swap the second equation for
the equation with the y term.
In this case,
we'll swap equations two and
three to get a y term in the second row.
Again, this is one of our
valid equation operations.
Now the second equation is y-z = 1.
And the third equation is 4z = 12.
We have no y terms underneath
the second equation so
there are no more terms to clear.
Finally, since we're
at the bottom equation
there are no terms underneath
the z term in the third equation.
Notice that our system of equations
is in a special form each variable
that appears as a leading term doesn't
appear in any further equations.
this form is sometimes
given a special name,
such as triangular form or
row echelon form.
In this lesson we will
call it triangular form.
However, this system does not
represent the same set of planes
as the system we started with by
adding and subtracting equations.
We do change the planes involved.
However, we have changed
them in such a way.
That the common intersections
of the planes remains the same.
Once we've reached triangular form,
our next task is to clear upwards.
So that way we isolate each
variable in its own equation.
First, we're going to solve for
z in the bottom equation by
multiplying it through by one-fourth.
Notice that this is the third equation
operation we had defined earlier.
This gives us the bottom
equation now reading z = 3.
To clear upwards we can add the third
equation to the second equation.
This makes the second
equation become y = 4.
Then subtracting the third equation from
the first equation gives us x-3y = 1.
Notice that z is now in its own column.
Now let's focus on y,
we've already solved for y, y = 4.
So the last step is to clear upwards so
that y is also in its own column.
To do this, we add three times
the second equation to the first
which makes the first
equation become x = 13.
Using just the three operations
we spelled out earlier
we have found the sole point of
intersection of the three planes
described in the original
system of equations.
Note that we can check
that the point 13, 4,
3 satisfies all three equations
in the original system.
I'd like to run through this set
of operations one more time but
this time including a plot of the three
planes that these equations represent.
That way you can see visually what
Gaussian elimination is doing.
One thing to keep in mind is that
the common intersection of the planes
defined by these three equations
should never change during
our operations that we use.
After the first operation, notice that
the green plane has rotated along its
intersection line with the red plane and
is now entirely horizontal.
The second operation,
which swaps two equations, just changes
the color of two of the planes.
The third operation, which multiplies
equation three by one-fourth,
doesn't change the blue plane at all.
By adding the third equation
to the second equation and
isolating the y variable.
The green plane which is y = 4, is now
perfectly orthogonal to the y axis.
Next, clearing the z variable
from the first equation
means that the red plane no longer
has any dependency on the z variable.
Finally, eliminating the y
variable from the first equation
makes the read plane perfectly
orthogonal to the x axis and
now the meeting point of the three
planes is easily identifiable.